LINE SO STRAIGHT AWAY.
MARTINEZ RIGHT IN, IN FRONT,
GRUBAUER CAN'T GET INVOLVED WIT
THE OFFENSE, AND PLAYS LIKE THAT
HAPPEN, YOU
HERE IS VINCE DUNN ON AND OFFLA
LARSSON LEADS THE TEAM IN TERMS
OF BLOCKED SHOTTHERE, AND BACK
FORAND TAKEN BACK BY PIETRANGEL
OUT OF THE CORNER, AND EICHEL S
FRONT AND HE ROOTS AND EICHEL W.
THEODORE.
SCORES!
RIGHT DOWN BROADWAY.
UNMARKED. THEODORE GOING DOWN
THE SLOT, NEY,
RASK,
HIS OWN TERRITORY.
HERE ISEW YORKED
EVEN TERMS ON THEE OLEKSIAK, OV
OUT.
AND OFF ICING.
>> J.T.: WITH A GOOD OPPORTUNITY
SHOULD PROBABLY PICK
UP A COUPLE. OUT, AND DADONOV,
DONSKOI,
WHITECLOUD WILL SEND IT IN, AND
SCORE!
DALLAS WENNBERG,
SKATE OF McNABB, AND RIGHT
THERE, THERE IS NOT A LOT YOU
CAN DO, AND KARSON KUHLMAN.
AROUND, AND KARLSSON CHECKED BYD
PASS BROKEN UP, AND HITIT
ALONG THE WALL.
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
POULIOT, AND IN WITH A SHOT. A
FROM FOOLS JOKE.
>> John: OUT TO CENTER, AND
EICHEL MOVES
SCORES, BANKING IT OFF.
>> J.T.: THAT'S THE DAGGER